Tekken 7 is a pillar of the fighting
game Community for a reason it's the
most refined that the 3D fighter has
ever been and there's nothing quite like
some good ass tacking
even so there's always room to evolve
after I got a few hours of Hands-On time
with a preview build of Tekken 8 it's
clear how it can take the franchise in a
bold New Direction that freshness is the
core gameplay mechanics specifically the
heat system and special style as well as
smaller changes that reward aggressive
play turning up the heat system the heat
system represents a fundamental change
with tekken's gameplay it's a brand new
gameplay mechanic for every fighter on
the Tekken 8 roster that at any point
once per round allows you to activate
heat to access new attacks open
opportunities for sick Combos and
enhance your character's core moveset
think of it as another meter that can
create an advantage for you by allowing
you to be more offensive in your
approach however the intricacies of
using the heat system effectively is
where the game gets more technical heat
burst is an attack executed by a single
button press that activates your heat
State and adds One stock to your heat
gauge if the attack hits you you get a
flashy little move that opens up a combo
opportunity and even on block it at
least staggers your opponent briefly but
you also have heat engages which are
more complex character-specific moves
that also activate heat and add two
stocks to your gauge you can follow up
heat engages with a heat Dash consuming
one heat stock which will send your
character running towards the opponent
giving you the chance to start a big
combo if the heat engager is blocked you
can still use a heat Dash to close the
gap and keep applying pressure
lastly there is the heat smash
regardless of how much heat and stock
you have left it will deplete the rest
of the meter in exchange for a powerful
attack akin to a super or ex move scene
in other fighting games those are are
just some of the options you'll be
working with while under a heat State
more passive effects are also crucial to
gaining the upper hand for example heat
can enhance certain moves to make them
do more damage or change the properties
of the moves themselves for example Jun
has a few strong attacks that also
inflict damage on herself but when she
has heat active this property is negated
allowing you to use those attacks
without penalty Zhou gets access to more
devastating combo strings King has
inescapable throws and kazuya transforms
into devil mode these are just a few
examples of how every character plays
even more differently now and leans
harder into their specific fighting
styles to bring a new depth and
diversity to tekken's brawls Tekken
series director katsuhiro harada also
sees this as a way to Intrigue players
into learning characters they they
wouldn't otherwise play quote because of
the differences in the heat system for
each individual character players will
start off with their Mane but then
they'll see the command list and see
what makes another character more unique
in a heat state that they'll gradually
want to try other characters as well and
we really think it will induce that
exploration it's also another layer that
high level players are going to have to
account for when facing certain
characters and attempting to read their
opponents the heat system has
essentially replaced rage drive from
Tekken 7 while they share a few
similarities heat is designed to give
players more control over how to use
their character throughout a match
rather than just when they're low on
health although each character still has
rage Arts at low Health which is now a
unified command input as such heat isn't
necessarily a comeback mechanic and is
instead a layer that changes the flow of
a match and open opens up new
possibilities in competitive play as
attack and Veteran I appreciate the
dynamic it creates smartly weaving the
core tenets of the franchise and its
characters into a mechanic that adds
depth without overshadowing the gameplay
Foundation that has made Tekken special
in the first place Tekken 8 is all about
offense the changes in core mechanics
were also intended to encourage more
aggressive play Styles and this
manifests in multiple ways for the heat
system in particular once it's active
it'll last for 10 seconds so you'll
definitely want to make the most of it
however the timer pauses when you're in
the middle of an attack animation or
when your opponent is down this means
it's possible to be in a heat state for
a lot longer if you play your cards
right attacks during heat as well as
other powerful moves in a normal state
will also cause chip damage but leave
behind recoverable Health which hasn't
been a feature so since Tekken Tag
Tournament 2 recoverable health is
indicated by a gray bar in the player's
Health gauge and it can be gained back
by Landing attacks further rewarding
aggressive play and while it's not
exactly a change to the gameplay system
itself rage Arts have been revamped to
now be bombastic over-the-top animations
with cinematic Cuts like they're out of
Dragon Ball fighter Z or Naruto Ultimate
Ninja Storm
no
just watch back laz's rage out in Tekken
8 and tell me he's not channeling his
best impression of Sasuke's Chidori with
his super fast lightning strikes every
character has a new rageart animation
and I can imagine the hype they'll build
as a player in a heated moment or as a
spectator on the edge of their seat
although they may seem like small
features Tekken 8 seems to be addressing
one of the criticisms of the competitive
scene slower and not so exciting moments
where players hunker down to play extra
defensively there can still be an
element of that in Tekken 8 but at least
both players have new offensive tools to
create avenues for turning the tide of a
match a special style of approachability
as if the aforementioned additions and
changes aren't enough to shake things up
Tekken 8 also features what's called
special style it's a simplified control
scheme for new comes to do cool Combos
and stronger attacks with easier strings
of button inputs many fighting games
have something similar to this like
guilt gears stylish mode or Street
Fighter 6's modern control scheme what
makes Tekken 8's special style different
is that it can be toggled on and off
instantly while in a fight it does not
take any frames or animations to swap
between normal controls and special
style you just press L1 or lb Android
controls switch schemes you can mix and
match these control schemes as part of
your approach in a match even harada
says that theoretically high-level
players can find ways to take advantage
of this system and incorporate it into
their repertoire quote it wasn't just
designed for beginners but for
intermediate and advanced players as
well from the start when we decided to
have it as something you can do on the
Fly that opened up all these different
possibilities that we were thinking of
when actually designing the system
itself he said harada continued quote
for more advanced players I guess you
could say one good example is in the
past with rage Arts some of them
required double button presses and if
you're in a tournament with your nerves
just going crazy even those players
would sometimes mess up so they would
sometimes bind it to one button to
reduce those kinds of risks we saw
similar things in our debugging team
where maybe they would switch with a
certain timing if they wanted to use a
certain movement and didn't want to mess
it up lowering the barrier to entry is
key to onboarding players but another
one of the noticeable shortcomings of
Tekken 7 especially by today's standards
was its lack of proper tutorialization
command lists suggested Combos and a
free practice training mode were all
well and good for those with some
fighting game or Tekken experience but
newcomers or lapsed players don't have
much to guide them I noticed Tekken 8's
in-game command list has detailed
explanations for what each characters
moves do and their properties and some
even include suggestions on how to
incorporate them into combos or specific
situations Tekken can get quite complex
and with a huge roster it's tough to get
good with each character so it gives me
hope that Tekken 8 could properly
address this area getting ready for the
next battle the new mechanics of Tekken
8 aren't necessarily new to fighting
games in general but in the context of
the series and tekken's core gameplay it
brings a whole other Dynamic that can
change the course of competitive play
upon first impression and with a couple
hours of playing the preview build I
immediately felt the nudge towards
playing aggressively which is the
developer's intent it's the Tekken I
know and love but with a few extra tools
that keep the momentum going in each
match I didn't have enough time in the
lab to see all the potential of the heat
system get a full grasp of my old
favorite in June or reacquaint myself
with Zhou but I can't wait until I can
unfortunately we still don't know when
Tekken 8 will launch but when it does
it'll be available for PlayStation 5
Xbox series X and S and PC